what's up everyone we were flowing out
to Bungie to check out the curse of
Osiris but first DLC for destiny - we'll
be able to talk about each section of
the game after Bungie live streams on
November 15th 21st and 29th for now all
we can show you is the first mission
gateway which covers how you get to the
lighthouse for the first time a
high-level explanation is that the vex
have converted mercury into a giant
computer called the infinite forest
that's capable of simulating multiple
realities kind of like the vault of
glass but way bigger the theme of this
DLC is mystery so you'll probably be
doing a lot of exploration and discovery
the main story revolves around osiris
who's essentially hacked into this
network and so it's not to get too
spoilery needs your help you'll mainly
be fighting vex in various time frames
on Mercury but the simulation aspect of
the plot means you can run into any
other race alright let's get to some
gameplay of the first mission from curse
of Osiris
there is a vex gateway near your
location osiris spent years studying it
it was convinced it was the door to the
infinite forest if it is still possible
to find osiris we need to open that door
icon array osiris is greater student
brother Vance Osiris is greatest fan
[Music]
[Music]
I'm so pleased Osiris has brought you to
me his most faithful servant considering
how you Revere a man who questions
everything I'm surprised how well faith
serves you the vex are at my door Osiris
has not returned faith is all I have
left
the Gateway to the infinite force a
place from which no one has ever
returned
not even Osiris here it is well I'm
ready if you are
we can't get through
if Osiris's ghosts were awake then maybe
she could help
Osiris preserve us you have his ghost
sukira
please please bring her to me
[Applause]
descendants we haven't seen these vex
since the vault of glass
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
neck's from different timelines are
converging on mercury
that's bad this is easier to get to than
their old place that's for sure
thank you
I don't know what I would have done if
Osiris hadn't sent you to me in return
the followers of Osiris can help you
revive his ghost we have a hidden temple
on earth takes Agera to these
coordinates I will notify the followers
that you are coming
now that the lighthouse is safe we can
prepare for Osiris's return all of the
lost prophecies are coming to pass I'm
finally going to meet Osiris
[Music]
you
you